that's keanu reeves crashing a british
couple's wedding turns out the actor was
staying at the same hotel no
way yes way ted the bride nicki
rhodnight says her husband james saw
keanu in the bar area after the ceremony
and invited him to come have a drink
about an hour later surprised he did but
declined the drink saying he just had a
long flight anybody want to trade seats
keanu took photos with the starstruck
couple and their guest and instead of
saying cheese everyone yelled speed
this isn't the first time keanu has
casually crashed a wedding back in 2018
he surprised a couple in california and
then another one in new york but he told
us this i once traveled to a friend of
mine's wedding
in france and for whatever reason the
driver couldn't find
the place where the wedding was at and
it started raining so i'm like hiding
underneath gutters people want to help
keanu reeves and then they they showed
up like it's like 12 hours later from
the wedding party oh
and then yeah so i missed the wedding
well here's something we wouldn't want
to miss a sequel to bring it on
gabrielle union teased just that when
she posted this cryptic reply to tweets
celebrating the film turning 22 she said
so isis might have a teenager
[Music]
isis is still doing cheers somewhere
with kirsten dunst probably with a
little lower back pain
e.t was with gabrielle and kirsten dunst
back in 2000 just before the iconic
cheerleading movie was released the fact
that she's a leader i think was my main
thing that drew me to the role
bring it
[Music]